What is the next element?
Hassium, I know nothing about hassium, should
we make
something up?
Element 108 – Hassium, I know absolutely
nothing about it.
However, the power of the periodic table is
that by looking at
the periodic table I can say ‘well its chemistry
has got to be a
bit like iron but it won’t be exactly like
iron because iron is a
light element and as the elements get heavier
going down
that their chemistry changes’. They tend
to have a larger
number of so called oxidation states and so
what I would
predict was that if hassium was not radioactive
it would still
be pretty poisonous and it might be an interesting
catalyst it
would probably react with carbon monoxide
and if it was
stable it would have probably made a great
addition to my
doctoral thesis work.